we're so used to seeing abby with trace
and now to see abby with evan can you
kind of compare and contrast their
different uh approaches and their
different energies
well
let's see they're
they're they're quite different i mean
evan is sort of like a puppy dog and
and trace is not like a puppy dog
so
he has a puppy dog but he is not a puppy
dog
right um yes they're they're just
they're they're very sort of they kind
of like just get at each other a little
bit they they
kind of take digs at each other and
and they kind of joke around a lot and
and
uh you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of humor between them
i want to dive right in since the season
five premiere of chesapeake shores has
completely you know just i think it's
brought a certain warmth and joy into
our hearts that i speaking for myself i
certainly needed and my first thing i
want to say to you huge compliment i
love this hair i love that you're also
rocking it in real life what inspired
this new hair and kind of these new
beginnings for abby she's the president
of the family company tell me about all
these new exciting things happening in
her life
um well you know this season for abby is
a season of new beginnings just like you
say you know she's
she's in a new place she's really
settled into her life in chesapeake
shores
she's
you know
trying to listen to her heart more and
do the things that are what's best for
her and herself and her family like her
girls and
and you know part of that is you know
leaving some things behind and
some of that weight and baggage is
coming out in her hair
was this your idea because it looks so
great on you
well
funny enough i'm i'm still nursing and
so this is my my my british botox
i've never heard that before that's
absolutely i think
who did i hear it from it was someone
like helen mirren or somebody like
amazing i heard saying i was like that's
so
yes i need bangs because i can't get
botox because i'm nursing so i'm gonna
get
bangs because i'm very expressive when i
talk my forehead is very wrinkly and it
bothers me so now i have bangs and i
don't have to worry about it it's so
great
[Laughter]
you're absolutely stunning and i love
that i don't know i feel like i feel
like new hair can really just do
something for a woman and it can signify
the beginning of a new chapter and i'm
curious
abby is such a career woman she's super
successful but with that of course comes
peaks and valleys what are some of the
hurdles that abby is going to be facing
in season five
some of the hurdles well you know i
think one of the things that is a
blessing and a curse is that she's
working with her
father been a dream of hers for since
she was six years old
and you know i think like anything that
is a dream it's not always what you
expect
and you know abby has proven herself to
be
a very very uh
well-equipped businesswoman she's very
strong-willed she's very stubborn and
guess where she gets that from her dad
yeah i wonder
so you know i think they they uh
it's it's a learning curve for them both
but they
love each other and they
have a lot of fun working together and
um
you know i think it's it's really nice
that she's sort of
clearing cleaning the the slate of
leaving the big company and working with
her dad now and really sort of bringing
in all of the family elements and and
having fun with with with all of that
i mean what can you tell me about abby's
career journey and and what we're going
to see unfold in season five because
like you said it's quite a drastic
change to go from a to b and especially
mixing you know the business with the
pleasure working with family are there
gonna be little bumps along the road
you know i think there'll they'll for
sure be some bumps but i think uh a lot
of those bumps happened i think last
season in season four with with just
sort of seeing what was really going on
at the big sort of conglomerate
corporation that she was working at and
and now seeing this opportunity to work
with her father and help him with
you know the things that he's dealing
with with dilfer the lawsuits and
everything like that and wanting to
really be able to put her focus into
helping him and
and building this you know business that
has meant so much to him over the years
i think that
you know we saw abby in
in season one in new york in her big
corporate office and like you know she
was really ladder climbing and doing
very well at it and then just realizing
that it wasn't giving her the life that
she wanted and
i i love the journey that she's been on
of sort of realizing how you can you
know be a mom and take care of your
family and your children but then still
maintain your career and and but doing
it on your own terms as opposed to you
know working for a big
company that doesn't really value you
100
amen to everything you just said and we
of course just watched episode two and i
have to tell you i picked up the phone
and called my dad after i watched that
scene between you and your father tree
williams um out on the porch you know
swinging on the on the balcony and you
sing a beautiful song together what is
it like sharing the screen with someone
like treat williams and having these
like really tender moments together
i mean i have to say treat is just one
of my favorite people when
and i love
where abby and
mick have sort of come in their
relationship in season one they have in
the actually the pilot they have that
big fight and abby says to him you know
your kids aren't okay and you're
focusing on work and
and
we need you basically and he really
stepped up and he heard her and he like
you know did a complete sea change and
he's around and he's there for you know
hammering away at jess's bnb and trying
to fix things and
bringing me on board and he's just
really
really stepped up as a father and i
think that's been really wonderful to
see
his relationship with all of his kids
grow and
and then treat williams i mean
he was danny zuku on broadway like
and i got to sing with him on the porch
like i was in the chorus on broadway
not on broadway i'm sorry i was in the
chorus in high school
uh for greece not on broadway
i don't want to get that wrong
mean are there broadway you you're about
it
are there any grease alongs in between
takes
constantly constantly like basically if
i just see with treat i'm like okay
greece what or grace treat what are we
singing right now because uh he likes to
sing raining on prom night and i like to
sing um
uh
what is the one that i always sing no i
can't remember
uh beauty school dropout that's
yeah we're huge dorks it's really quite
funny so i was when i saw that that we
got to sing together it wasn't greece
but it was tour so it was also pretty
great hey fingers crossed fingers
crossed for maybe like a greased tribute
episode in what could be a season six oh
my gosh i hope so oh my gosh let's put
it out
it's jesse or a movie a greece movie
a great remake movie i don't know if
that would work but
honestly i'm here for all of all of the
above and you know i i want to segue a
little bit and talk a little bit about
romance um because fans have been with
you and with abby on this journey
throughout several seasons and in
episode two we said goodbye to trace so
i'm just kind of curious from your
perspective megan where is abby's heart
at right now
you know i think that
abby's been through
so much with trace and
what i sort of realized this season
which was really interesting
it just in terms of like the healing of
the family
is
you know trace was someone that was
really important to her
emotionally when her family was going
through a whole lot of
like tumultuous times with her mom
leaving and just her taking care of her
siblings and everything and trace was
you know her her rock for that and
i think a lot of her sort of feelings
about him are mixed up in that time and
i think the fact that she's able to sort
of say goodbye to him now
from a place of you know
love and
happiness that she wants what's best for
him but knows that what they want is
just not the same thing which it sort of
shows the healing of the family and that
she's able to
sort of let go of that person who was
there for her at a time that
was really difficult but now she has you
know her family as her rock now because
her family has come together in a
totally different way and
so i think it's sad and you know anyone
that you have
great history with and love for
it's sad to say goodbye and you know i
i'm sure that trappy fans are going to
be
you know heartbroken for a little while
because it's it's a sad thing but i
think it's also
really beautiful that they're just
realize that they're not in the same
place and they're not right for each
other anymore you know and
you want something that was the past
that has all this you know
beautiful memories but then when you
bring it into the present it's just not
it's not what
you think are expecting sort of
totally and i think you hit the nail on
the head there like i loved personally
even though i am sad about it i loved
that it was kind of the beginning of two
people going on separate journeys that
are gonna suit them best and i think
that's a great message in life it's okay
to go on different roads whether it's
with a romantic partner or just friends
um i think being in constant pursuit of
your best self is is a wonderful message
and we really are seeing abby do that in
season five can you tease like in what
ways she will continue to self-develop
well
uh
yes i can i think one of the things that
was really apparent for me for this
season with the new hair and the
new job and everything is abby's really
trying to have more fun this season and
be more light-hearted and sort of
really slough off all of the
you know last few years like her divorce
and she's been through a lot of stuff
over the few years that we've known her
and
and this year is about her trying to you
know
what get her groove back on her what i
can't remember what someone said about
about her
[Laughter]
any specific scenes or
uh memorable things that fans should
definitely keep a lookout for
uh well there's there's some singing and
there's some dancing and there's some
running and
there's some uh abby gets a new hobby
this season which is
really
awesome and i was not sure what i felt
about it when i first read it
but abby takes up karate
girl kind of amazing
with her girls yeah she joins her girls
uh her girl's hobby and and starts doing
karate and she's really good at it and
she really realizes that she likes to uh
have an outlet for all of that sort of
pent up
uh
big corporate energy that she doesn't
have an outlet for anymore so she's
gonna hit some bags instead of i guess
yell at people
i love it it feels very therapeutic
right yes very therapeutic yeah
okay so you told me abby's good at at
karate or taekwondo how does megan feel
about it how has the training been for
you
um
it was it was pretty great i've i've
done it in the past for other jobs i've
i've played some cops in in the past
where i had to do some training for it
and i but i haven't done it in a really
long time and i have to say
that there's a scene where i
i do a high kick and they did not need
to use my stunt devil
so
it went pretty well
i love it it looks like it's all me
it's all you high kick in 180 degrees
i'm kicking yeah
only with my left leg though i only i'm
like zoolander i only kick left
and it's true you have more flexibility
in one leg than the other so it is
left leg is your lucky leg i guess so
yeah
i love it and look i see this huge smile
on your face and i know obviously i'm
talking to you right now megan the
actress not not abby but i have to
believe that this smile and this energy
um is gonna carry over into abby's love
life i'm really excited i know this
sunday's episode we're gonna meet a
certain robert buckley who's coming to
town as this new character named evan
who is evan what can you tell us about
him
well evan is a pain in abby's butt
unfortunately
what does that mean
evan is this like you know
happy-go-lucky
positive super
just annoying pain and abbies but
so evan comes into town he is working on
a project with uh abby and mick
and
you know he
he is very demanding he's got a lot of
money
and he's just always right there and he
just he can't get away from him and
and andy yeah he's really really
irritating
okay so
fair to say it was not exactly love at
first sight
no
definitely not i would i would for sure
not say that at all
but they have a very nice working
relationship uh sort of
can you just but there's a lot of they
really they really butt heads
they um
they uh they they they love hate each
other let's say they
they love hate each other
more hate than love
what's this type of energy um that
definitely can manifest in interesting
ways um can you describe what evan and
abby's dynamic is you know kind of as
they get more acclimated together they
start working together does does the
groove start to unfold a bit
um i don't know if i would call it a
groove per se but
when
when they meet each other
evan is riding a hoverboard and i think
you know that is not really what abby is
expected uh has has come to expect with
dealing with business people
uh he's he's sort of like another child
to her and for i think evan
you know abby's not impressed by him or
his money and i
you know she is this straight shooter
and tells him like it is and he's not
used to that and so there's actually a
line at the end of when we meet him and
he says you know uh
you don't like me and i don't like you
so we should work together and this is
gonna be great and he's bang on
wow oh my gosh i can't wait to see all
this unfold especially you know coming
off
we're so used to seeing abby with trace
and now to see abby with evan can you
kind of compare and contrast their
different uh approaches and their
different energies
well
let's see they're
they're they're quite different i mean
evan is sort of like a puppy dog and and
trace is not like a puppy dog
so
he has a puppy dog but he is not a puppy
dog
right um yes they're they're just
they're they're very sort of they kind
of like just get at each other a little
bit they they
kind of take digs at each other and
and they kind of joke around a lot and
and
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of humor between them because i think
when you're working with somebody that
you don't really like but you have to
like because you're working together you
kind of have to find a way to relate and
so that's sort of how they relate
is just by making fun of each other sort
of yeah yeah
yeah
um
pretty it's pretty fun
i have to tell you when i spoke with
your co-star andrew francis in our last
hallmark live virtual event i loved what
he said he said that he thinks robert
buckley brings a certain lightness and
like i don't know um renewed
breathability to the show that he's just
like a breath of fresh air to have what
was it like for you to be filming scenes
with rob buckley
i think that's a great that's a great
description um yeah he's he's he's a
breath of fresh air he just ca he came
in and i mean that's a hard thing to do
to kind of come into a season five where
with a like a family show as well like
we're all
pretty entrenched in our roles with each
other i'm the oldest and the boss of
everyone clearly
as i'm sure they will all tell you
and to just sort of swoop in and be like
hi i'm the new guy and he was just you
know great at it he fit in just smoothly
and got along with everyone and and yeah
and i think our we have new show runners
a new show runner this year thief sutton
and then he um
he wrote for cheers years and years ago
and there's definitely a little sam and
diane
uh dynamic that that he brought to
the the evan and abby relationship which
we really really loved
do you have fun
i'm the
2021 version of that i love it exactly
is there a favorite uh behind the scenes
moment that you can share um maybe
working with rob that you really enjoyed
throughout season five
working with rob
ah
well i i don't know about
rob specifically but there there is a
scene
where tree williams does the worm
and i don't know if it's going to make
it to air or not
but it happened
and i don't know if you're going to see
it
what was your reaction envision it
are you in that scene
oh yeah we're all in it
what was your reaction when you saw
something as epic as tree williams
your joy
and
laughter
i feel like that actually sums up this
season is treat williams doing the worm
he's gonna kill me for saying that
it's a brilliant tease okay here's my
last roman and then and then we'll move
on
you know we want to see abby happy at
the end of the day as viewers we just
want her to be thriving and to be happy
in all facets of her life
can you tell the viewers the chessies
does abby find romance
and and happiness again in season five
i think abby is the happiest you will
ever see her
this season
for sure a hundred percent
and you know let's also not forget that
jay is still around jay ross
mr j yeah
he's
like he just does he just is like just
he just keeps on trucking
because abby just kind of seems a little
hesitant where we're at right now but i
don't know
i think abby is just going she's going
with the flow this this year i think
whoever whoever is the right fit is
going to
win the day
that's very fair i love it and look we
are obviously invested in many facets of
abby's life personally i just love the
sister scenes i'm very close with my
sister in real life and seeing the
o'brien girls together sipping wine or
coffee like it just those scenes truly
kind of just warm my heart what can you
tell us about abby's relationships with
her sisters this season maybe tease a
little something about the wedding
episode
ah yes the big wedding um well you know
the sisters are just awesome they're
those scenes are
they're our favorite to do
i think that
whenever we talk to the writers they
always say they love writing them and
you know
it never feels like we get to do enough
we always say that we need to do a three
sisters movie somehow we all go
somewhere together and so we just get a
whole movie of three sisters because we
just have so much fun together and
amelia and lacey are two of my best
friends now like we
we have kids that are the same age i
made them all get pregnant
that's that's so wild that you're you're
on yeah these together your kids are all
like a couple months apart because yeah
i i started like you just gotta do it i
mean just do it
are you having
oh yeah we have playdates we were joking
we needed to have a nursery on set
because there were five babies this last
season
um
because uh one or i'm sorry there were
only wait one two uh so jessica sipos
also has a baby who plays brendan penny
uh kevin's wife and her baby is also a
couple months apart
so
a couple of us were pumping and like
nursing on sets and their babies running
around and it was
you know that that should have been like
a documentary on its own because it was
just so funny
i was gonna say that's gonna be like
plus a peak shores season 75 like we're
gonna see your kids in the future
this o'brien legacy
[Laughter]
just thank you fun going
right
yeah can you tell me about close
relationships that you fostered with
these women on the show i think that's
one of the things that i truly love
about chesapeake shores it's strong
women supporting one another being there
for one another tell me about what that
means to you and uh is there a group
chat i assume there is between you lacy
and julia what goes down
there's there's definitely a group chat
between us there's a group chat between
everyone
um yeah i mean it's
it's funny because we
you know sometimes you hear about shows
where there's a lot of women involved
and
they don't get along or there's
animosity and whatnot and
from sort of the beginning
uh we just we just all kind of clicked
right away and have always you know
had each other's back about everything
you know our husbands are all friends
which is pretty funny and um
yeah you know like i remember uh lacey
had an audition for something and amelia
and amelia and i were texting her like
good luck and
yeah we just we keep in touch and
they're wonderful they're just wonderful
people and i think that that shows on
screen and they're also like
they have beautiful hearts and they're
wonderful actresses and
and uh yeah and barbara and diane and
jess like we just we're really lucky the
the um the whole the whole cast
especially the women are just fantastic
the boys are okay too right
they're fine
that's what i know is so real and being
as close as you are with lacie in real
life what was your reaction when you got
to see your on-screen sister all done up
in her bridal veil and gown
oh that was
it was a lot because she eloped and so
we weren't there at her wedding
and
um we're good friends with her husband
as well and so you know she obviously i
i kind of said that she needed to bring
her actual husband so that they could
take a picture of her in a wedding dress
and the whole thing and
i wish that they had because it was very
like it was it was like being at her
wedding and it's just the wrong guy
there but still
you had all the other elements the
different guys
it was amazing i actually
i think uh
i might have some behind the scenes uh
videos of wedding day that uh when we
get to wedding episode i may post
okay i hope you do i'm gonna hold you to
that but for you
is there something you can tell me that
was very memorable you know get get to
get the chesties excited about you know
hallmark does these wedding episodes so
beautifully um what can they expect to
see in this beautiful wedding episode
oh my gosh well
lacey looks is like a vision she's like
a bridal
barbie doll in her wedding outfit
and
just the whole everything
i mean i don't really want to tell you
that many that much because you know
it's going to be amazing and you know
it's going to be beautiful and wonderful
and romantic and like
it's just
chesapeake shores plus a wedding we've
had a couple but
this one is is pretty special you know
it's pretty special
okay there is dancing
is this where the worm occurs maybe
maybe okay okay we're definitely going
to keep going
we'll keep our eyes peeled keep your
eyes peeled yes
uh and then just speaking to season five
in general
is there one scene that you're just
truly most excited for the chessies to
see
i mean
it's gotta be the wedding i think
everyone's just
everyone can't wait for the wedding it's
it's it's so exciting and
and so well done and
yeah
the wedding well i i want to get your
reaction because when i spoke with your
co-stars in the last live event
a lot of them seemed really excited
about the season five finale
what's your reaction to that
oh
yeah
yeah
what happens
there it's a kind of crazy finale
it's kind of crazy
there's a lot that happens
yeah like a lot i'm not gonna say
anything because
there's a lot that happens
all right you're a pro i can tell you've
done this a few times before
but you definitely need to tune in for
the finale and i think to
you know that for the chassis that are
sad about trace leaving and
sort of a different direction that the
show is taking this year i hope that you
will stick with us because
we all had so much fun this season and
there's a lot of you know like andrew
said there's a lot of lightness that has
been brought to the season and i think
after
covid and everything
it's really
it was really you know therapeutic for
all of us to get to sort of be in that
space of just having fun and having fun
with each other and so i hope that you
uh
you know i hope that you stick with the
season and see it through to the end
because the the writers did a wonderful
job and
and everyone's story lines this year are
so you know in depth and intricate you
meet a lot of new people and there's
just there's a lot of
love and laughter and drama and i think
that you know all the things that that
that you want to see will see so
stick with us till the end and then and
then make your decision
i think i encourage everybody to stick
with it especially i've seen episodes
one and two which have both been just
fantastic i have to imagine the best is
is yet to come as you guys continue to
deliver week after week yeah my final
question before i let you go i asked
your co-stars this so i wanted to ask
you as well
if you could tease the season five
finale of chesapeake shores
in one adjective what would it be
can it be a sound
[Laughter]
what
what happens
is there anyone basically that was me
when i was reading it was like what
and that wait what
wow so the season five finale even had
you shocked
oh my gosh yes
like yeah
okay so basically we need a season six
because i need to find out what happens
now fingers crossed let's put that out
into the universe
can you tell me
if that
expressive reaction that you just had is
it in terms of romance is it a family
uh
conundrum
everything
wow
like almost every single person has a
has a something
almost every single person
yeah good goodness okay well i think
that is a wonderful reason to con and i
tell you what you will not see it coming
because i didn't
really even all your years and if you
didn't see it coming please tell me
because
you're a psychic
[Music]